lives. That's good. A lot of Christian
lives, but Oh, hold on a second. Hold on
a second. Hold on a second.
>> Do you have do you have more time?
>> Yeah, I have a few more minutes. Sure.
>> Okay. All right. Two questions. Why do
some Islamic laws seem harsh like
stoning or amputation? And what do you
think about people who talk about like
quantum physics and frequency?
>> Looks like central dog found somebody he
can lie to. Do [clears throat] you think
that is like innovation or do you think
that
>> I don't think it's a lie that they'll
let me join but let's see
>> um regarding Sharia and why punishments
are so harsh. Okay,
>> let's see. I I'll only wait a little
>> the Sharia would come from Allah himself
right so by def by definition it cannot
be unjust.
>> Why? Because we know Allah is just. So
as human beings, we might perceive
something as harsh when we don't
understand its wisdom or context. Right?
So for example,
>> looks like she's
goal is not cruelty on on contrary, it's
to protect the five universal
necessities which is religion, life,
intellect, family, and property. And all
rulings revolve around safeguarding
those five pillars of civilization. So
the purpose of severe laws, right, is
not brutality. For example, the
punishments, the cutting the the hand of
the thief or flogging for adultery like
you said, right? The Quran states that
uh the purpose clearly Allah says in
chapter 2 verse 179,
>> "And there is for you in legal
retribution
life, oh people of reason." What does
Allah mean? Allah means that strict laws
preserve life and societ uh societal
stability because their deterrent effect
prevents chaos and greater harm. So
historically speaking these punishments
were rarely applied precisely because
their
evidentiary
standards are extremely high. So theft
on on one hand only if proven beyond
doubt
not out of hunger or necessity. Adultery
requires four upright witnesses to the
actual act.
>> Practically impossible except an open
immorality. So the harshness is radical
uh uh rhetorical. It scares potential
offenders more than it punishes.
>> Right?
>> So think about this. How can you commit
adultery with four people there? The
only way you would be able to do that is
literally if you're committing
>> I'm not about to just be sitting here
for this.
>> You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. people are telling her in the chat
to let me up.
>> So Allah lays down harsh harsh uh
rulings so that people refrain from
doing it. For example, if I told you uh
let me try to think of an example. Uh
sister don't eat an don't eat a egg. If
you eat it, you shall pass away. Are you
going to stay away from
>> me? She sees the comments.
>> Okay. So if Allah says don't do this,
>> the punishment is this. Obviously any
stable individual in their right state
of mind is going to say ah I don't know
if I'm going to eat that egg because I
know the consequence of me eating that
egg and digesting it. So that is the
reason for some of the harsh laws.
>> Do you know logic?
>> Yeah. Don't don't ever bring this guy
up. He's a blasphemer of Islam. He he uh
endorses people ripping the Quran,
eating the Quran, burning the Quran. I
would actually advise for you to block
him and stay very very far from him.
>> He is a filth of an individual.
>> I won't put him. All right. And then my
last my other question would
>> y'all see that these DA dudes are some
of the biggest cowards that you can ever
come across. biggest cowards. They will
talk to a nice young lady like that who
doesn't know anything about Islam that
they could just spill spew lies to.
Every time I show up, this man hearts
heart races. His heart races when he
hears my name, when he sees that I'm in
his vicinity. [snorts] That the Dawa
guys, I hope that y'all got a good
laugh. They are cowards, man. Block him.
You never let him up. I advise you. He's
a blasphemer. He's a sick evil
individual. Well, the only thing I do is
read, y'all. The only thing I do around
here is read. Y'all make sure y'all go
ahead and clip that. Y'all y'all can go
ahead. All my clippers, I need y'all go
ahead and clip that. Go ahead and clip
that and make fun of it. And also, uh, I
don't know if Sandra's watching, but
also put up there, if you're going to
clip it, clip the parts where Central is
begging for my attention and calling out
for me. logic.
Logic and then put it put put those two
together. He's always begging for me,
man.
>> That was a good conversation that you
had with a Muslim there.
>> Thank you.
>> So, you're accrediting all these things
to Christ. I would ask you who Christ
accredited all the works to.
>> Well, he accredited the works to
himself, the spirit, and the father.
>> Well, who was doing who was working in
the flesh of the Messiah?
>> Who was working in the flesh of the
Messiah?
>> Yeah. Who was dwelling?
>> Or do you mean who just working in him?
Period.
>> Now, who did Jesus say was dwelling in
him doing the works?
>> So, we got him saying that the father is
in him. He also says that he's doing the
works. And he also says that he's does
the works by the spirit.
>> Well, yeah. He says the father who
dwells in me does the works.
>> Does he also say that he does the works
as well?
>> Well, yeah, because when God the father
does the works, Jesus is doing the
works. But Jesus is not doing the works.
it. God the one doing the works through
the Messiah.
>> So, so just to be clear, can we can we
agree that Jesus says that the works
that he's doing are done by the father
are also done by him and are also done
by the spirit.
>> Yes, they have to be done by the son
because the son is the physical image of
the one who's doing the works.
>> So, can we agree then that you know they
work in they work together in the works
that Jesus was doing?
>> Absolutely. You have to. Yes.
>> Okay. So, let let me ask you this
because you're saying like in the the
flesh of the Messiah, do you what what
do you believe about about Jesus? Do you
believe that he's a distinct person from
the father or what what are your
thoughts?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. Okay. Good. And so, so what do you
what do you believe about Jesus? Do you
believe he's a creature? What do you
think?
>> Hear these words of Israel. Jesus was a
man that God did the miracles through.
So,
>> So, you believe he was a man?
>> Yes, sir.
>> You believe he was a mere man?
>> No, not a mere man because he was a
sinless man. He was the prophet, the
Messiah. So he wasn't just a mere man.
>> Do you believe that he pre-existed his
human birth?
>> Not literally. He pre-existed in
prophecy.
>> In prophecy. So that's that's not
pre-existence because that's just
potentiality. But I'm talking about
actual existence.
>> Well, in heterosis, the Jewish people do
things differently. Like like in
Jeremiah, I have made you a prophet
before you were born. So Jeremiah
existed in God's purpose and plan before
he was born and he was made a prophet,
but this is before it actually happened.
>> Yeah. So that's still potentiality.
That's not Jeremiah actually existing.
Can we agree?
>> Right. That's that's my point. Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. So, you're saying that Jesus
didn't actually exist prior to his human
birth, but he was always in the plan of
God.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. And so, All right. So, let me ask
you this. Okay. Um, in Joel, I'm sorry,
not Joel, sorry. In uh Jude 1, in Jude
1, let me just pull this up real quick.
This is what it says. It says uh for
certain people have crept in unnoticed.
I'm reading verse four. For certain
people have crept in unnoticed who long
ago were designated for this
condemnation. Ungodly people who pervert
the grace of our God into sensuality
and deny our only master and lord Jesus
Christ. So you agree with this verse
that Jesus is our only master and lord,
right?
>> Yeah. It's separated from God, but yes,
I do.
>> Yep. distinct from the father. No
worries. Okay.
>> Well, it's God. It doesn't say the
father. It says God.
>> Well, yeah, it's in context. It's
talking about the father. There's
there's
>> How would you know that?
>> But if you're a trinitarian, how do you
know that it's specifically speaking
about the father?
>> Because a lot of times through these
letters, you'll see that God that the
father is referred to as God a lot. It
was just common for the father to be
referred to as God. And then they make
the distinction between the master and
lord Jesus Christ.
>> Right? But that's the problem is I know
that the father is the only true God. So
whenever I see the God in the Bible, I
know it's the father. But if you're a
trinitarian, that creates a problem
because now you're trying to figure out
could that be the Holy Spirit? It could
be. See, you have to pick and choose of
what God is actually this person. Like
in Revelation,
>> I don't the the verse the verse is
explicit. Judah Judah is explicit in
context.
>> But it doesn't say the father though.
>> He does. He doesn't have to say the
father there. He said it earlier. Well,
like this is the revelation of Jesus
Christ which God gave him. See, now
we're we're not we're picking which
person of the Trinity want to insert,
>> brother. It says Judah, servant of Jesus
Christ and brother of James to those who
are called beloved in God the Father and
kept for Jesus Christ.
>> So God is referred to as the father
here, right?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. And so then when we continue
reading and he mentions God again, we
know he's talking about the father. And
then he makes another distinction just
like he did earlier saying uh and our
only master and lord Jesus Christ. So we
see the distinction. Right.
>> Right. Yes we do.
>> All right. And then in verse 5 he says
now I want to remind you although you
once fully knew it that Jesus who saved
a people out of the land of Egypt
afterward destroyed those who did not
believe. So it says Jesus was the one
who saved uh Israel out of the land of
Egypt and then destroyed the Egyptians
and those who didn't believe. So he
would have to exist prior to his human
birth in and not in a prophetic sense.
He he actually had to be there, right,
doing these things way before he
incarnated into flesh.
>> Well, I wouldn't see it that way. I
think that we have prophecies that the
Messiah would be coming. They got
strength and nourish from that prophecy
knowing that the Messiah would be
coming. Because let's face it, if the
Messiah was back there, he would be all
over. He would be worshiped. He'd be
honored. He'd be prayed to. We wouldn't
even be debating him. Okay? He would be
around the throne with God the Father
and the angels. We would see him doing
something. Gabriel, Michael, Satan,
we're not arguing their pre-existence.
Why? Because we actually see them doing
something. The son, we never shown him
there. So, he's there in prophecy and in
vague inferences, but you'll never find
him being worshiped, him being called
God, him being called the creator, or
doing anything in the Old Testament
figure. Uh,
>> so when So, are you saying that Jude is
wrong when he says that it was Jesus who
saved the people out of the land of
Egypt and then afterwards destroyed
those who did not believe?
>> No, I'm saying that it's it's correct,
but we don't have any scripture that
actually shows Jesus doing that. I'm
saying it's prophetic. We do.
>> When we do How wait I'm sorry how is how
is it prophetic because prophetic is
speaking in the future right talk talk
foretelling things to come this is
talking about the past this is
>> this is re re revision revision revising
history that's wrong word it's looking
back you know what I mean it's looking
back in history and what happened and
Judah is saying that Jesus was the one
who brought the Israelites out of the
land of Egypt and then destroyed the
ones who didn't who didn't
So Jude says Jesus was actually there
active and actually saved the people out
of the land of Egypt. Retrospective.
Thank you. That's the word I was looking
for. Good lord. So either Jude is lying
here and wrong and is just, [snorts] you
know, just out of his mind saying that
Jesus was the one who was there who
saved the people out of the land of
Egypt and then destroyed the people who
didn't believe. or he's correct and
Jesus pre-existed his human birth and
was there all along even with the uh the
people of Israel back in the Exodus. So,
which one is it?
>> Am I in the matrix or can you hear me? I
can't like I think I was breaking up
there in a second ago.
>> I can I can hear you. Can you hear me?
Were you Were you able to hear what I
said?
>> I can hear you. Yeah, just kind of maybe
my connection is not as good or
something. Um well, you know, like I
said, it's I think some some
translations I would have to look at
that, but there are variants on that
particular passage. So there's a varant.
Yeah. So yeah. So there so there's a
variant when it says the Lord. I don't I
don't try to base a lot of this stuff on
um verses. I'm like let me plug my thing
that verses that are that are arbitrary
that don't say Jesus. Some translations
will say the Lord. But my point is
>> but we we know who the Lord is according
to the context, right?
>> Well, no. Well, forcing, you know, a lot
of people are called Lord in the Old
Testament. Uh
>> no, we're not I'm not talking about
that, brother. Wait, I'm sorry. I don't
mean to cut you off, but I'm I'm not
talking about that. I'm saying in in
Jude tells us who the only Lord is,
right? In the verse right before it, he
says
>> he says Jesus Christ is our only Lord.
And then if we were go if we were to go
with the variant reading
>> um about verse 5. Now I want to remind
you that although you once fully knew it
that the Lord who saved a people out of
land of Egypt destroyed afterwards
destroyed those who didn't believe. Jude
just told us the ver in the verse prior
who the Lord is. That's Jesus Christ. He
said it verbatim. So either way you go,
it's still Jesus.
>> Well, like I said, it's Yeah. I mean,
like I said, a lot of things are
prophetic. So when they like like like
the spiritual rock that followed them
was Christ. Well, Christ wasn't
literally a rock that was following
them. It was a spiritual rock that was
following them and that was Jesus
because Jesus was the prophet coming
after Moses. See, so
>> according to according to Deuteronomy,
who was the rock that followed them?
>> It was a spiritual
>> Yeah. The spiritual rock that followed
them was Christ because they were being
baptized into Moses and the rock that
was following them that was coming after
Moses was Jesus. But it's not
>> No, no, that's that's not what I mean.
In Deuteronomy, it literally says that
there was a there was somebody who was
identified as the rock who followed them
and remained with them in the
wilderness. Do you know who it said it
was?
>> Well, the rock would be God the Father
through the angel, right? Because the
angel
>> wasn't Well, it doesn't say God the
Father. It it does say it says it does
say Yahweh though. It says Yahweh.
>> And so Yahweh says that he is the rock
in Deuteronomy that he is the rock that
was with Israel throughout the
wilderness. This is mentioned multiple
times. And then we get in and what
you're quoting 1 Corinthians 10 where
Paul says that Christ was that rock that
followed Israel. So according to who
that rock is in Deuteronomy, the rock is
Yahweh. According to Paul in first
Corinthians, that rock is Jesus. That
means that Jesus is their rock. Again,
demonstrating that he was the one there
with Israel saving them, sustaining them
throughout the wilderness, saved them
from the land of Egypt. This you're
you're helping my point.
>> No. Uh let me let me let me make a
couple points. So throughout the Bible,
the only one who's called God in the Old
Testament is the father. Never the son.
Ever. You always
>> true.
No, that that's he will be called great.
He will be the son of God. He will be He
will be called. He's not He is God.
>> It literally says his name shall be
called wonderful counselor, mighty God.
>> Shall be called, not that he is God. No
shall be. That that's a that's a
prophetic future.
>> It's call is it is it right there? Is it
calling him Is it calling him God?
>> No, he will be called mighty God. Not
>> when it calls when it calls him the
prince of peace. Is it calling him the
Is it calling him the prince of peace?
>> He will be called will.
>> So it's not so it's not identifying him
as the prince of peace. is in the future
like
>> okay so then so it so it is identifying
him as the prince of peace right
>> eventually he will be great he will be
called the son of god he will be mighty
god but he's not
>> so I I got you according to the to n
Isaiah 9:6 it says the son to be born
that he is uh he shall be called
wonderful counselor mighty god
everlasting father prince of peace
>> shall
>> is is is the verse identifying him as
the prince of peace
>> shall be. That's a
>> Yeah, I know. So, is it So, is it
identifying him as that?
>> Yes, it's a future prophetic instance.
Yes.
>> Okay. So, we got that. We got we got the
uh we got it identifying him as the
prince of peace. Does it identify him as
the wonderful counselor?
>> Sure. Wonderful count. Lot some people
would argue that's actually Hezekiah,
but I would go with Jesus.
>> No worries. All right. So, because we
know they're wrong, so who cares what
they argue? So it identifies him as the
wonderful counselor. It also identifies
him as the mighty God. Right.
>> Will be. Yeah. But people are called God
in the Bible. That's a common title.
>> But you just told me that only only the
father is called God.
>> Only the Yeah. Only the father's called
God Almighty. When they when they
address somebody as God, you Lord are
our father. You are our creator. We are
the work of your hand. They never ever
refer to the son. Somebody never refers
to the son as God. But I want to say
something.
>> But but hold on. You you you made a
you're you're making a lot of a lot of
claims here and you're going away from
what you're saying which you said you
what you said at first was is that only
the father is called God in the in the
Old Testament.
>> Now you're saying well well other people
now so now you changed it to God
Almighty. So
>> when I when I when I make a case when I
speak about God Almighty when I say God
I mean God Almighty. Uh when
trinitarians use the word God they think
that that men who are called God that
doesn't have any relevancy. But I want
to say something. The Greek word, the
Hebrew word there is L. In Ezekiel 30
31:11 and Ezekiel 32:21, men are called
Elgaboreim. Elgabore. That's the simple
title for ruler or lords. It doesn't
have anything to do with being God
Almighty.
>> All right. So, in the next chapter when
it says that they that the Israelites
will return to Elgibore, the mighty God,
who is that?
>> It's it's it could be translated as
mighty ruler or mighty ones.
>> No. Well, no. It means mighty God. Who
is it? Who is it? Who are they returning
to?
>> Well, I mean it can be used differently,
but I would say Yahweh.
>> Okay. So, Elgibore, we see Elgibore is
referred to as Yahweh. Yahweh is the one
who is Elgibore, the mighty God. And
then we see it used for uh the son to be
born as well. Never do you see this
phrase anywhere used for other than
Yahweh. Isaiah 9:6 and Isaiah. People
can pick up the any interlinear and look
at Ezekiel 31:11 and Ezekiel 32:21.
Elgabore, the the the Hebrew word there
is L. Eel and it's translated as God or
mighty ones or mighty ruler. So that's
just simply not true.
>> So So uh can you for the verse that
you're talking about? Uh can you can you
show me where it affirms that they are
Elgore?
>> Yeah. Ezekiel 32:21, the mighty ones,
the mighty Elgaboreim, that's plural for
Elgabore. Let's see this. Ezekiel,
right? Ezekiel
>> Ezekiel 31:11 will show you the the
Hebrew for their e l ruler or mighty
ones.
>> Okay. So, let's see. Therefore, thus
says the Lord God. You said verse 11,
right? Okay. Yeah. I see.
>> 3111 is L. It means they don't use
>> I got you. You said what? in 3111 that
the word that they use for God l in in
Isaiah 9:6 they change it in the Hebrew
in Ezekiel 3011 it's the eel is not god
there it's ruler or some other word
>> is but is l there is it l gibbor
>> it's l but they changed the word god
there to something else like ruler
>> okay so therefore thus says the lord god
because it towered high and set its tops
among the clouds and its heart was proud
of its height. I will give it into the
hand of the of a mighty one of the
nations.
>> He shall surely deal with it as its
wickedness deserves. I have cast it out.
Foreigners, the most ruthless of nations
have cut it down and left it. On the
mountains and in all the valleys, its
branches have fallen, and its bows have
been broken. and all the ravines of the
land and all the peoples of the earth
have gone away from its shadow and left
it. Uh, and he's talking about so he's
talking about this punishment that's
going to take place on these people who
had it looks like they had these pride
and towered high and yada yada yada. So
where does it say that they're like
where do you get it from that that God
is acknowledging that these guys are
actually
>> no no that that's the Babylonian king
there but when they when the Hebrew in
the translations they take that Hebrew
word L which is used in Isaiah 96 in
Isaiah 96 because of bias they've
shifted the Hebrew word to change it to
God which it can be or it can simply
mean mighty ones or ruler. So in this
particular passage if you look at the
Hebrew word L it's changed as mighty
ones. In Ezekiel 32:21, it's Elgaboreim,
which are the mighty ones. So, mighty
gods, mighty ones. It's all based on
translation bias.
>> Let's see. I want to just check this
really quick.
>> Yeah, I did this when I was a
trinitarian. I went through all of the
passages and it's just a lot of
deception, a lot of tricks, a lot of
change.
>> Let's Let's see. Just slow down. Slow
down. Verse 11. Ezekiel 31.
>> 32:21.
>> 32. Sorry. Ezekiel 32:21. Oh, so 21, not
11. Well, no, both. 3111. You have that
right. And then 3221. Sorry. Both.
>> So 3111. [clears throat] 3111.
>> Okay.
>> So I'm in the right place. All right. So
3111. Uh deliver
uh
Okay. It says
um L.
>> Yeah.
>> And Not not giore.
>> No. L is the is is the word that they're
using. So when
>> I know but you you said it says Elgoreim
like it was the plural of mighty ones
>> in 3221 that's the Elgoreim. So the word
>> so 30 so just to be clear so 3111
doesn't use Elgore right
>> it uses the word L which is used
>> I don't care about that I'm talking
about the phrase Elgibore it's not used
in Ezekiel 30 31
>> no because it's because it's the one the
mighty one so it's when when you use the
word the critical word is l that's the
word that we're focusing on
>> I don't I no it's not I'm focusing on
the phrase el gibbor that's the phrase
we're looking for
>> yeah because because when we do but but
what is the word they use to translate
it as God in Isaiah 9:6. It's L. So in
Isaia in Ezekiel 31:11, that same word L
is not God. It's used to say mighty
ones.
>> That's fine and all, but we're talking
about the phrase Elgibore. The El
Elgibore, this phrase, mighty God, which
is the exact same one. This phrase is
only used that we see in Isaiah for
Yahweh in the next chapter. So you're
saying that you're saying that you're
saying that Elgibore I want you to to
hear what I'm saying. You're saying that
Elgibore is also you this same phrase is
also used for others who are who are not
God and stuff like that. So that's what
I want to see. So
>> no the thing is 21 right?
>> Yeah mighty God.
>> What we're focusing on is God. What the
word God is mighty the go the boreim is
irrelevant. So the word God is what's
relevant. What they use for God. The
word they use for God in Ezekiel 31:11
is not God. They they sh they change it.
Look at anybody can pick up the Hebrew
interlinear. It's the same exact word.
It means God, but they shift it for the
Babylonian king to put ruler instead of
God. It can easily translate it as
mighty ruler or ruler. The ruler. That's
my point.
>> Okay. I got you. So I I I it's a it's
interesting to me because I'm seeing uh
that the phrase Elgibore is used for the
son and Yahweh in the next next chapter.
It looks like what you told me that I
would find looking for I misunderstood.
You're you're kind of splitting the word
al and then goreim. I'm I'm trying to
look for elgivore for somebody. But if
if this isn't the case. You you said you
said that God that that in the Old
Testament God is the only one who's
referred to as God. But that's that's
not that's I I mean Isaiah 96 that's not
true. You got you even got the angel of
the Lord who's called God as well.
>> Well, right. But I but I want to make my
what I made my point was is yes when
they declare somebody as God. You are
God. You are our creator. They address
only the father as the creator. Only the
father is called God. So when I say that
in the Old Testament only the father is
called God. Yes. By God Almighty. We
know that other people are gods. Other
people are judges and rulers. That's my
point.
>> Yeah. I'm not I'm not talking about uh
God in some generic sense of mighty one
or whatever. Ruler judge and stuff like
that. We're talking about Yahweh, the
one who's identified as Yahweh, right?
And so, okay. So, with this being said,
the angel of the Lord, he identifies
himself as Yahweh.
>> Yahweh God, not just any other God. You
agree?
>> Yeah. Because he comes in the name of
God.
>> No, not because he comes in the name of
God. Coming in the name of God and being
God and have and having the name Yahweh
yourself, two different things. And
according to the scripture, only Yahweh
bears the name Yahweh. Would you agree?
>> No. Because the Bible tells us that
angels come in the name of God.
>> Okay. So, I'm going just let me just
read this for you real quick. Nehemiah,
what happened? Nehemiah 9:6. It says,
"You are Yahweh alone."
>> Yeah. Is anybody else Yahweh according
to this verse?
>> No. But they come in the name of Yahweh.
Big difference.
>> Right. So coming to in the name of
Yahweh doesn't mean that they are
Yahweh. Right.
>> Right. They're not.
>> They can't they can't claim to be
Yahweh. They can say, "Hey, I come in
the name of Yahweh, but they can't
claim, hey, I'm Yahweh." Right.
>> No. They speak on behalf of God the
Father in first person, but they're not
>> Can they claim Can they claim to be
Yahweh? Yes or no?
>> Out of their mouth, yes. because they're
speaking the words they're commanded to
say, but they're not claiming personally
that they're God. They're saying exactly
what God the Father has told.
>> So, just to be clear, as if if what's
your name, by the way?
>> I just go by uh CM.
>> CM. Um let's say let's say that you sent
me with a message to someone. Um can I
claim to be CM
>> in the Hebrew culture? Yes, you could.
>> No, I cannot. No, I cannot. Yes, you
can. And that's and that's extremely
dishonest. This is this is why this this
is why I mean I'm giving you verses. Uh
you're not giving me you're you're not
giving me any verses that's explaining
what you're saying.
>> This this the verse Nehemiah 6 says you
are Yahweh alone,
>> but you're telling me that oh others can
also claim to be Yahweh.
>> No, I didn't say that. I said they're
speaking on behalf of God.
>> No, no, no. I said they're speaking on
behalf of God.
>> I'm I'm going ask you this. I'm going
ask you this question one last time
because my patience is starting to run a
little thin cuz I'm sensing dishonesty.
CM, I'm going ask you one last time. Can
anybody other than Yahweh claim to be
Yahweh? Yes or no?
>> They're not claiming to be Yahweh.
>> I didn't ask that. Can they do it?
>> They can speak as God himself. Yes.
>> I appreciate you for coming. Thanks for
coming, man. Whoops. accidentally
removed Jeffrey.